Die deutsche sondern sind bereits
Im interstellaren raum angekommen wollte 1 wird das erste entfernte stern system schon in rund
40.000 jahren erreichen gs45 allerdings immer noch in einer entfernung von
1,6 lichtjahren und die schwester sonde voyager 2 wird den stern ross 248 ungefähr zur selben zeit in einen ähnlichen
abstand erreichen die ersten von menschen geschickten besucher eines anderen stern systems wenn wir nicht bis dahin den warp antrieb
Erfunden haben aber schon heute können wir in den
Orionnebel reisen wie das gehen soll jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Ja es sind absolut faszinierende bilder die uns hier vom orionnebel erreichen allerdings ist dort kein
raumschiff hingeflogen ist könnte sie auch gar nicht, so schnell bewegen allerdings liegen uns durch die weltraumteleskope hubble und spitzer
So detaillierte daten vor so dass jetzt erstmals ein flug durch den orionnebel simuliert werden konnte und das ist wirklich der hammer
dass wir von hier aus einen, so konkreten blick in diesen nebel werfen können immerhin ist der
1344 lichtjahre entfernt für diese animation lieferte hubble bilder aus dem sichtbaren
wellenbereich und spitzer aus dem infrarot bereich der orionnebel
Befindet sich in unserer milchstraße und ist ein entstehungs gebiet für sterne
Errechnet hat diese reise ein team unter der leitung von
Frank summers vom space telescope science institute die reise beginnt im
außenbereich des nebels und führt dann in das zentrum
Des nebels hier werden neue sterne geboren und liegen eng beieinander sie sind auch für das leuchten des nebels verantworten
Durch die ionisierende strahlung der sterne leuchte der nebel
Im sichtbaren bereich und ist so als einziger nebel mit dem bloßen auge von der erde
aus zu beobachten die stärkste lichtquelle bietet dabei das doppelsternsystem
Täter uhren ist. Zäh ich finde es absolut irre dass wir solche sternen reisen durch moderne computer inzwischen
unternehmen können
Das sind wirklich absolut faszinierende bilder
Beeindrucken wie hier die sterne, im nebel verteilt sind und auch wirklich wahnsinnig schön
Ich hoffe dass in zukunft noch öfter solche
fantastischen animationen zu sehen bekommen das video macht wirklich appetit auf mehr und weckt auch ein bisschen sehnsucht hoffentlich entwickeln wir irgendwann, mal
So etwas wie den warp antrieb und können das auch in wirklichkeit sehen wahnsinn wenn er solch unglaubliche bilder
Nicht verpassen wollte und auch alle anderen videos dann drücken wir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht den
Genau auf die glocke denn nur dann
werdet ihr auch wirklich über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klicken das erste foto von erde und mond
auch ziemlich irre ansonsten bis dann
bleibt da